[music]
>> This compilation mashallah, it's
in 12 volumes, which gives the names of
the raw bees and everything and the
details.
Details means why it is sahi, why it is
zaif. This scholar said sahi, but it is
zaif according to the ruling of
Professor Dr. Z.R. Azmi's authority.
You may differ.
You and I cannot differ, but another
more this can differ.
Same what I've done,
it was a long project.
I was a little bit
eager to get results.
I chose even the head of the department
of Jamia Tul Imam of the Sunnah
department to do the same project
simultaneously.
And that hasn't been completed.
Inshallah, it will complete soon.
Started about 3 years back,
but it will be complete faster because
we have a group of teams, associate
professors, it's a teamwork.
His
analysis may be a little bit different.
Dr. Zear Rahman Azmi says, "If not all
more than 99% is there."
Sheikh Falih al-Saghir
who was the previous head of the
department of Jamia Islamia, he says,
"I'll only take from 10 books.
The Kutub al-Sittah and some other books
which will contain 85% of the sahih
hadith according to him.
So, his version will be a little bit
smaller. May not contain 16,500
hadith. May contain nine, eight, I don't
know.
Most of them are there. But, Dr. Zear
Rahman Azmi said, "Any sahih hadith you
quote, it will be there. But, it will be
mentioned there that this hadith that is
there
which says ballighu anni walau ayah, it
is in Bukhari and also there in this and
also in the this.
We'll give references.
Hard work.
It will not be like one, two
in Bukhari. It will be there. Now, if
you read this volume, inshallah, he said
99% I am a bit more safe. I said more
than 95. I like being safe.
So, I said at least more than 95% and
more than 95% even covers 99. So,
they're debating.
I say more than 95% of the hadith that
are sahih are there in Al-Jami al-Kamil.
And the name that he gave to his book is
Al-Jami al-Kamil fi al-Hadith al-Sahih
al-Shamil.
In 12 volumes. Inshallah, it will be out
very soon.
Then he had made a mukhtasar version
without giving the arguments, only
giving the names of the rawi. It's in
five volumes.
Mukhtasar means
condensed.
He's not giving the arguments. He's not
giving the famous za'if and mawdu'
hadith which are counted as sahih.
Only the sahih hadith with only the
narration without the argument.
I told him, "Baba, make it more short.
Five volumes, people don't have time to
read the Quran here today.
So, he agreed to make it short without
Ravi. I said, "Without Ravi, I cannot
quote my quote."
So, it was difficult for me. You can't
quote Hadith without I said, "Yes, for
you as a scholar." I convinced him,
"Sheikh,
Ravi should be there, but
only say Muhammad said Rasulullah. Or
you can name only the name of the
Sahaba.
So, after a lot of
he agreed that he'll make a shorter
version, one volume
with only the matter rather than the
list of narrators.
So, in his main there's list of
narrators. The argument why say, why not
say this scholar said that this 12
volumes.
Mukhtasar, no argument, only sahih
Hadith
with narration.
I told him, "Make it more condensed."
One volume, no narrators also.
You're right, but I want to be
practical. He said, "No, no, no, I
cannot do that."
I said, "Why? It's not haram."
So, he agreed to make it only matter,
but write the references.
And that inshallah when it will be out,
it will take another 6 months, I don't
know. Inshallah, we will translate it
into English first, Urdu, then Bangla.
And as many languages as we can, so that
will be good for the Dawah.
If you read this,
halas,
you can say I've read 95% of the Hadith.
Which is difficult.
Don't think I've read all this, huh?
Don't get the wrong impression that I've
We have referred references we used.
You say, "Oh, was that here?" I said,
"All these they say it is from my
personal library, that's a different
thing."
And this is just a small percentage drop
of my library.
But don't think I've read Yes, we did it
when required there for references.
Some books we have read once, some books
many times, some books 50%, some books
5%, some books 1%, depending upon the
requirement. But if we read this 16,500
Hadith, it's possible, okay, it will
read.
1 million Hadith?
Possible, but not probable.
Difficult. At least for a layman.
Like you and me.
So, this project was very dear to me and
alhamdulillah it's complete in Arabic.
May Allah make it possible that the
Mukhtasar when it's also out then we'll
make a more condensed version and
translate into as many languages as we
can. I like doing things which are
unique
and best.
So, one of the unique projects
which Allah made it possible
to support is this project.
And I made a soft copy and I made I gave
it to it. I like spreading. The more
people read, the more people benefit
more reward. So, this is
something new which very few people
know. What information I gave you now
very few people know.
It will become more popular after it is
released.
So, it's just coming hot from the oven.
And when we say Quran and Sunnah we are
talking in Turkey here
is the Sunnah. If not all, 95%
alhamdulillah.
Scholars may differ.
The difference is always going to be
there.
It's not a Hadith, but it's going to be
So, at least something is there that if
not all, okay, someone will say 90%. I
said, "No problem, 90%." 90% is there.
So, any Hadith you quote
if it's there,
easy to check, huh?
Say not there,
say
some reference we have.
So, Sheikh Nasiruddin Albani had done a
good work and Dr. Ziyaur Rahman
alhamdulillah. And to tell you the
background of Dr. Ziyaur Rahman, you'll
be shocked to know
that
he was originally an Indian.
More shocking is
he was not born in a Muslim family. He
was born in a Hindu Brahmin family.
And after accepting Islam he had to run
to Saudi Arabia. He worked in the Muslim
World League and from pillar to post.
And now imagine, then he learned Arabic,
he mastered the Arabic language.
Became the head of the Department of
Sunnah, can you believe?
A mushrik.
Who Allah gave Hidayah to.
He wrote a book from
Ganga to Zamzam.
Ganga is supposed to be a very pure
river
for Hindus. From Ganga to Zamzam. And he
had written many books in Arabic.
More than 20. He had written a book
the encyclopedia of the Quran which is
very good. It's not here. Wrote in
Arabic, translated into Hindi and many
other languages.
He's done great works and may Allah
reward him inshallah.
And may Allah accept his works and may
Allah make a lot of good things come out
from this last work that he has done in
compilation of Jami al-Kamil, inshallah.
There are the books, a collection of
Hadith.
Fiqh as-Sunnah
by Sheikh Sabik.
Fiqh as-Sunnah, very good book on Fiqh.
Then you have Bulugh al-Maram.
Now Bulugh al-Maram
is a compilation
of Hadith which talks on Hukm.
All the Hadiths which talk about ruling.
On Fiqh in Bulugh al-Maram, it's a
compilation.
I think there are more than 1,000 1,300
Hadith.
But
in it also weak Hadith, unfortunately.
It's a very good book.
There's another book
called as Umdat al-Ahkam which is a
shorter version of this.
Which has removed the duplicate, has
somewhere a little bit more than 400
Hadith. Umdat al-Ahkam, in which on
Peace TV we also have a series of Umdat
al-Ahkam by Sheikh Assim al-Hakeem.
This Umdat al-Ahkam has removed the
duplicate Hadith from Bulugh al-Maram,
removed even the unauthentic Hadith.
Only the bare minimum of Hukm.
How to do Wudu, how to do ghusl, about
salah is there.
So, if you want to read a book of Hadith
on hukum,
the best book that you should read first
is Umdat al-Ahkam. Unfortunately, it's
not available in English.
Unfortunately.
There is some translation there. Some
work is being done.
But, if you ask me which book should I
read
of the book of Hadith,
for ruling, number one is Umdat
al-Ahkam.
Ahkam means the hukum,
the book on hukum.
Because Bukhari has all. It may be a
hadith, it may be hukum, it may not be
hukum. It may have variety. So, if you
want to know the do's and don'ts, if you
want to read a book on Hadith, number
one, most important, Umdat al-Ahkam. I
don't know yet. It has not been
translated into English. There are some
parts available here and there.
And people are I think compiling on it.
Bulugh al-Maram is available, but this
is little bit more voluminous.
And it has some Hadiths which are da'if.
But, the best would be Umdat al-Ahkam.
Riyad al-Salihin, again a compilation.
Then Imam Zakariya Yahya bin Sharaf
al-Nawawi al-Dimashqi. Even I don't know
the full name. Imam Nawawi, the short
form.
But, this is the commentary done by
Hafiz Salahuddin Yusuf, who's again from
Pakistan, a great scholar.
He also comes on Peace TV.
Alhamdulillah. Riyad al-Salihin again is
a good compilation, but again each
compilation has got its pros and cons.
All compilations again are not all
authentic.
When you quote,
most are authentic.
But, some compilations are fully
authentic also.
Like Bukhari, Muslim. So, this is again
a compilation by Imam Nawawi.
La
ilaha illallah.
Muhammadun [music]
rasulullah.
Arju ridhaka ya Allah. Antar rahimu ya
Allah. Habni a'taka ya Allah. Antal
karimu
minka a'tauhu ya Allah. Antal a'dhimu ya
Allah. Fika raja'u ya Allah. Antal
halimu
Ar-rahmanu as-sattaru malikul mulki
al-ghaffaru
al-wahhabu al-mannanu
al-muta'ali.
Ar-rahmanu as-sattaru malikul mulki
al-ghaffaru
al-wahhabu al-mannanu al-muta'ali.
Ar-rahmanu as-sattaru malikul mulki
al-ghaffaru al-wahhabu
al-mannanu al-muta'ali.